ces bulletins de santé étaient suivis
par les démocrates qui craignent
désormais que donald trump s'empresse de
nommer celle ou celui appelé à lui
succéder
avec la mort de ruth bader ginsburg
cette question est désormais au coeur de
la bataille politique que se livrent les
deux candidats à la présidentielle
américaine
pour joe biden pas question de laisser
son rival à la maison blanche nommé un
nouveau juge à quelques semaines de
l'élection
il n'y a aucun doute à avoir
les électeurs doivent choisir le
président et ce dernier a le devoir de
choisir le type de justice qui sera
examiné pour le sénat c'est la position
qui avait été adoptée en 2016
quand il restait dix mois à attendre
avant la présidentielle
c'est la position que le sénat américain
doit désormais avoir mais donald trump
n'entend pas laisser passer une telle
opportunité
malmenés dans les derniers sondages il
compte bien nommer un juge à la cour
suprême avant la présidentielle
son objectif est clair s'assurer du
soutien des électeurs de la droite
religieuse en nommant un juge
conservateur de préférence
opposée à l'avortement est favorable au
port d'armes et le milliardaire a
semble-t-il déjà un nom en tête
j'ai même dit que je m'étais peut-être
cruz parmi les candidats à la cour
suprême vous savez pourquoi je les fais
vous savez pourquoi je les fais parce
que je voulais être sûr d'avoir
quelqu'un sur la liste nous avions
environ 45 personnes incroyables les
plus intelligents les meilleurs
la crème de la crème quelques jours
avant sa mort russe bader ginsburg avait
confié ses dernières volontés à sa
petite fille ne pas être remplacés temps
qu'un nouveau président n'aurait pas
prêter serment que le prochain locataire
de la maison blanche soit républicain ou
démocrate
une chose est sûre le dernier mot
reviendra aux sénateurs selon la
constitution américaine une fois le
choix du président arrêté c'est au sénat
d'avaliser le choix du candidat